🎵 Gérer l'atterrissage, j'suis hyper chaud j'ai vite la🎵
🎵 Weapon que tout l'monde s'arrache, j'te tue pépouze t'es minable 🎵
🎵 J'le vois ton piège collé au plafond (Grillé !), mec tu vas faire dans ton pantalon. 🎵
🎵 J'te vois au loin tu restes statique, j'te la mets dans la tête puis je m'astique. 🎵
🎵 AR, pompe ou uzi, j'gère mes 1v1 easy 🎵
🎵 Retour à la réalité, j'suis pas Gota j'suis Squeezie 🎵
*😥Soupir😥*
🎵 Et ce mec sur un toit lointaaaiiin (Ah ouais...)...Qui snipe et a un gros killfeed (Ah l'batard !) 🎵
🎵 Et ce Joueur qui campe dans les toilettes (Mais non !), qui boit ses popos de shield. 🎵
🎵 Et ce feeling désagréable, d'être en retard dans la tempête... 🎵
🎵 Et ces pensées noires qui te traversent, quand tu perds face aux joueurs adverses 🎵
🎵  (Refrain) J'mate des streams pour m'entraîner, mais je reste un joueur tout pété... 🎵
🎵 Chaque game on m'appelle Bambi, facile à kill comme Squeezie 🎵
🎵 J'ai voulu faire Top 1, sans l'aide d'aucun copain, sans la puissance d'un forain, ni le charisme d'un vilain  (Ha ha!)🎵
🎵 J'ai voulu faire Top 1, sans l'aide d'aucun copain, sans la puissance d'un forain, ni le charisme d'un vilain  (Je vais le faire x2)🎵
🎵 J'ai fait d'la merde j'suis méprisant (Oh le con ...) , Il m'a niqué même s'il a 10 ans 🎵
🎵 J'manque toujours de composants (Bah t'es nul quoi ... ), J'construis si lentement c'est épuisant... 🎵
🎵 J'fais des escaliers j'ai posé mon tremplin, j'me suis éclaté il a cassé la base (Bien joué...)🎵
🎵 Des jours à tenter l'Top 1 sans enclin, j'fais un truc beau,sur les réseaux j'le partage 🎵
🎵 J'traîne sur la map, à chaque ennemi j'panique, j'transpire à balle, j'serai mieux sur l'Titanic. 🎵
🎵 J'bois les grosses popos avant les p'tites, J'mets un feu d'camps alors qu'j'ai un kit 🎵
🎵 J'vise le lampadaire au lieu du mec (Il est con ... ), J'pète tous les murs pour trouver l'coffre 🎵
🎵 À chaque fois j'me fais oneshot au pompe, si y'a un beau skin dans l'shop, c'est qu'j'ai loupé l'offre 🎵
🎵 (Refrain) J'mate des streams pour m'entraîner, mais j'reste un joueur tout pété...🎵
🎵 Chaque game on m'appelle Bambi, facile à kill comme Squeezie (Ha Ha Ha) 🎵
🎵 J'ai voulu faire Top 1, sans l'aide d'aucun copain, sans la puissance d'un forain, ni le charisme d'un vilain (Ha Ha) 🎵
🎵 J'ai voulu faire top 1, sans l'aide d'aucun copain, sans la puissance d'un forain, ni le charisme d'un vilain (Ouais x4) 🎵
🎵 J'veux faire Top 1 moi ! (Ah carrément!) 🎵
🎵 J'veux faire Top 1 moi ! (Haha) 🎵
🎵 J'veux faire Top 1 moi ! 🎵
🎵 J'veux faire Top 1 moi ! (Je vais le faire x2) 🎵
🎵 J'veux faire Top 1 moi ! (Ha ha ha) 🎵
🎵 J'veux faire Top 1 moi !.... 🎵
Musique : Squeezie
Mixé par Martin Cannavo
Clip monté par Théo Meunier
👍🏻Pouce Bleu , Abonnez-vous et Partagez 👍🏻